we're here in the GameSpot stage for the
last appointment of the day we've seen
so many games but now we're coming back
to an old favorite I think it's fair to
say wonderful what I remember from last
year having a good time with Gary clay
pleasure to meet you Owen Johnson how
you do my friends hey you guys are here
with the plants vs. zombies garden
warfare but not just regular ass plants
vs. zombies garden warfare this is
coming out on next-gen planer right now
today I also haven't trained before so
yeah let's hop on it first of all I want
to ask you when was it released it feels
like not that long ago so it came out on
Xbox one and Xbox 360 in March and it's
coming out on ps3 and ps4 and in August
on 19 and then isn't it coming at a PC
it is coming out see seen yeah yeah it's
you're staggering it yeah yeah what's
what's coming in December yeah Sega
Saturn
oh yeah he's not able go back we're
going back Mega Drive so with PopCap
we're quite a small dev team so we
actually focus on like individual
platforms at a time it's not the same
kind of we're not equipped to do a huge
triple a and once push but trust me it's
gonna be good
cool what I first of all want to ask you
is a bunch of people were asking me for
the past couple of days is hey you guys
were pretty good about adding content to
the game posters for the Xbox versions
and that sort of stuff is that gonna be
on the PlayStation 4 version yeah yeah
absolutely
so we're working on a bunch of new
add-on content at the moment
unfortunately can't talk about it right
now but with PlayStation all the
additional content that came on Xbox one
and Xbox 360 will be there at launch and
then we'll continue to support it post
launch with even more content excellence
while we have it up here so let's let's
shoot to the gameplay yeah and check out
what's going on so we're just sharing a
couple of the customization Minds right
now so if you preorder on PlayStation
you get either a Sly Cooper Ratchet and
Clank or a Fat Princess customization so
you can see a little it's that random no
you can get depends where you get it so
the only one that you can't get from a
retailer is the fat princess or what I
want there you go we that's digital
replace ok ok let's take a look at the
fat princess for a second so here's the
chump disguised as a zombie in the fact
princess works that's pretty good that's
pretty mean we're going to jump straight
into our garden ops which is our 4
player online
but we're gonna play a single player for
you today yeah because obviously all
that stuff as the hasn't there hasn't
been set up yet we're gonna quickly
create a match for you so yeah so the
main gameplay modes within the game
you've got 24 player online and that is
kind of a team deathmatch style but also
a gameplay mode called gardens and
graveyards rush style gameplay mode
inspired by battlefield yeah and that is
the zombies pushing the plants back and
they're trying to protect the base and
there's always a huge surpise at the end
of each one of the maps which is my
favorite mode yeah I didn't know if
you'd played it or if you oh yeah we
played a bunch of it it was one of these
games that on paper was kind of like
really yeah come in now and then you
play in this AI art is actually kind of
embarrassing level of depth that's what
we're trying to get you know get across
I mean he's done really well on the Xbox
platforms we've got you know over 1.3
million people playing right now out
it's so yeah so it's done great and
we're we're really excited to bring it
to PlayStation I think people are gonna
be very excited about the gameplay yeah
I imagine it's one of these games that
people were sort of pining for as well
yeah especially to PC crowd because it
was it was already yeah yeah Xbox oh
yeah PC is gonna be exciting as well
we've actually put in a bunch of new
features for PC you know things very
specific things like really dialing up
the different level of visuals you can
get into in the customization all the
kind of key bindings you'd expect but
also and it's got a dynamic UI so if you
want to switch between a gamepad or
playing with a keyboard a mouse cool
it's going to change on the fly so we're
gonna jump in without a fire P or
commando P whichever you like best and
these fire P action so 5p is one of the
variants he's going to give you a damage
every time
you can skip through these dudes there
we go so he likes them too much how to
use the ability so this is a map called
Port scallywag and when we launch this
map had your kind of generic zombies in
there right now with one of our updates
we added all pirate zombies okay so
you're gonna see the pirate zombies in
this map so when you play this the
objective is to plant a garden and then
protect it against multiple waves of
zombies and usually you play at four
player we're gonna play a single-player
right now and if you were playing live
on us on a live server right now people
could jump in and it would dynamically
shift the difficulty level depending on
how many people are playing so we're
gonna put it right down in the center
there always always a bonus garden as
well that will give you more points it's
much harder to defend because it has
limited lines of sight for instance and
we've got a few of the different plants
here that we added post-launch so let's
put up a bamboo shoot' which is one of
my favorite plants so it's kind of like
an artillery strike and this is our in
favorite place to put it a good
line-of-sight here and then we added
things like the fire P in the ice P and
they're gonna do damage over time or
slow the guys down and I loved about
this mode is that it's the one that is
most reminiscent of plants vs. zombies
proper yeah it was this the first one
you guys came up with and this was
actually the last one became really yeah
so we started with team deathmatch and
really wanted to get that right and then
we knew we wanted a really big set piece
style gameplay which was the guns guns
and graveyards maps but then we spent a
really long time trying to get co-op
right you know we weren't sure exactly
how we wanted to do it we knew we wanted
to have some of the tower defense level
elements as you just said and that's
where you're gonna see bringing in those
classic characters from the original PBZ
and also new characters coming in from
Fuji 2 as well and so yeah that was the
last one but it came together really
quickly and just became very very fun
has now do you guys have had success on
the Xbox one and PC and I presumably I
imagine is probably gonna do quite well
on the PlayStation as well and is there
a tendency to try maybe drags what some
of the stuff you've done here back into
the plants vs. zombies fatality yeah no
no it's a really good really good
question so we constantly talk between
the two teams so this games developed op
in PopCap Burnaby and then the PZ 2 team
are in Seattle so we're constantly
thinking about how we can affect the two
universities
thing that brings Plants vs Zombies
universe together it's obviously Dave
and zomboss and and the time travel
element with penny which is applying RV
that dave has so you'll see that when
you start this I love for people who
don't know any of this they're supposed
to be blowing their yeah yeah so I mean
the backstory becomes even more
ridiculous of course good this is
effectively a big fight over a taco but
crazy Dave will drop the plant heroes in
and you basically in this game mode
you're surviving ten waves and then an
extraction wave of a while he brings the
army back after he's been you know going
searching for the space rocket on for
furniture
so are there any fundamental differences
between this one and what we see in
already on Xbox one the customization
items you'll definitely see one of the
main differences is you can actually
play it remote play on beta okay so if
you if you like a bit of remote play on
Peter I have a beat here and I really
enjoyed that gameplay modes you can take
it if you play all of the different
gameplay modes including boss mode on
Vita which is which is great and really
exciting for us the other thing that
we're doing is you can actually use the
PlayStation app on a tablet now the
universal version of it and you can use
that to play boss mode so you can have a
top down view with a bow field and and
bring in airstrikes printing heals
bringing revives and you can use that
app now on launch which will be really
exciting we've also brought in a bunch
of new options to this you'll see these
special wave kind of conditions you see
right now he's got to get me oh no
garden damage in order to get that extra
bonus so we're bringing in some new ones
of those as well obviously the new
characters and then we've got a bunch of
content we haven't announced yet I'm
guessing you're gonna try and ensure
feature parity between yeah yeah or all
of these versions you don't leave anyone
else that's right yeah and I have to ask
this question because I love asking you
it's Super Dome and it's anyone who's
bringing again to ps4 what are you using
the touch pad for the church pad will
bring up the the screen for the check in
your score do it so do it hit the
touchpad action there you go it's my
favorite thing sometimes you get
sometimes you get some you never know no
I know it's like that yeah it's like
their lucky dip yeah yeah just to show
the taco a location on the map
and so continuing on then I guess you
know you've released it earlier this
year your PC versions coming this month
yeah August you've got PlayStation 4
what's the lifespan for this game do you
think it's honestly as responses as long
as we our players are excited about it
right now we're having some amazing
feedback and we're thinking about a
bunch of new game modes which we're very
excited to bring in the near future so
they're there we can't talk about
exactly what they're gonna be yeah it's
going to be very excited before our next
update that we're working on is very
much focused on team play that's the
only thing we can really say right now
but we've really taken a lot of feedback
on board about things like party systems
so that people can get can invite their
friends to the type of game play and and
really working on the code the actually
competitive style game modes so we found
that you know a lot of people when they
first look at the game the because of
the cartoon style visuals you know
people think that it's are they gonna be
a very simple game or there's no real
competitive element to it and since
we've launched we found that people are
really really taking it seriously on a
competitive front and so we're spending
a lot of time thinking about what that
might look like so I just got a little
bit of a hint all right that's cool
plants vs. zombies garden warfare was
definitely a gaming stuff the GameSpot
office by surprise as a bunch of us are
really into it and I know that there's
probably a to me it seems like one of
these worth of math games that I imagine
when it comes in on PlayStation 4 you're
probably gonna get a bunch of extra
people hopping on there yeah that's what
I hope your absolutely awesome
Gary Nolan thank you so much for coming
on I probably pleasure having you here
what a wonderful game to finish up yeah
your demos here on the game a little bus
wave right at the end as well
perfect so though we go to disco I'm
trying hard and there you go in the
tombstones
nice work